Tariel: Hello! My name is Tara. I will use dragon. I'm in windows 10 Dragon actually speaking for our terminal navigation and chrome as my browser. My task today is to explain.
First
Tariel: insert the credentials in front, then after I
Tariel: as well activate the login and go to the next page, I will explore.
Tariel: I will be exploring and clicking through some of the activities.
Tariel: I will use. Click, show links, mouse grid, move down Scroll and mouse, Scroll Mouse and
Tariel: dictation commands to explore and access the areas on
Tariel: on the demo page. Now, first i'm gonna use a show links
to get to the email box, to
Tariel: copy and paste that I use name. They they never use
Tariel: tab to those on the password box, and use the dictation of spell to spill out the password, and then I said to click, log login.
Tariel: mouse, click.
Tariel: show links.
Tariel: choose 3
Tariel: press, control, V.
Tariel: Press, control, v
Tariel: tab.
Tariel: spell
Tariel: cap Foster.
Tariel: Awful
Tariel: bravo!
Tariel: Let me
Tariel: scratch that. Hey?
Tariel: Scratch that
Tariel: limit!
Tariel: hey?
Tariel: Move Left one.
Tariel: Move there.
Tariel: backspace. Move right.
Tariel: Move right!
Tariel: Echo
Tariel: Delta!
Tariel: Mike Oscar. One exclamation. Mark.
Tariel: click, okay.
click, login
Tariel: as you see that everything works with that. Now, I'm going to scroll through this the home page or the course.
Tariel: Check out, check it out. Look while I move down and my scroll down. After that I'm going to access one of the areas that you see in front of us
Tariel: moved down 4 times.
Tariel: moved out for
Tariel: move down. 8
Tariel: starts rolling down.
Tariel: Stop scrolling.
Tariel: Okay, Move down, works the scroll down works. Now i'm going to click on one of the links that you see in front of me. First i'm gonna use the one that i'm use the command by by saying click, accessibility, user experience.
Tariel: So if that will work, If not, I'm gonna you will show Link or a
Tariel: I'm gonna use the mail's grid because I re you show link. Are you ready to use click? But i'm a using. I was grid here. Then I will go back. Come back and use a a show link or click, but an excellent
Tariel: That was great.
Tariel: 4
Tariel: 5
Tariel: click.
Tariel: Okay, that didn't work. So I would scroll down a little bit to click on accessible accessible user experience.
Tariel: Scroll down.
Tariel: move, mouse up. Sorry about this move, mouse. move, mouse up.
Tariel: move mouse up
Tariel: faster. click.
Tariel: Okay, that did that works that time. So I' to get on the link to click on it. Now I must go through some of this stuff
Tariel: that you see in front of some of the activities that you see in front start scrolling down.
Tariel: Stop!
Tariel: Stop.
Tariel: scroll up.
Tariel: move down 16,
Tariel: move up, mouse up.
Tariel: click.
Tariel: scroll it down.
Tariel: stop scrolling
Tariel: Mouse click.
Tariel: Okay, that works. I'm gonna go to Back Arrow and i'm gonna try to let click on that link. That's a I that you just say, before I click the user fonts using front.
Tariel: click, back, arrow.
Tariel: click back here.
Tariel: Press back here.
Tariel: Miles agree.
Tariel: One one
Tariel: 4
Tariel: like
Tariel: show links.
Tariel: She was 11.
Tariel: So that works. Now i'm gonna go back. I'm gonna close this.
Tariel: I'm gonna go back to the previous page, and i'm gonna go to the next one
Tariel: move, mouse up.
Tariel: click.
Tariel: move mouths down.
Tariel: mouse, flip.
Tariel: scroll up.
Tariel: Okay, Everything look good. It's up to the click back error. I don't know Why is this not working?
Tariel: But
Tariel: it might be just my my software. For right now, now i'm going in on use click
Tariel: to click into the the introduction to accessibility.
Tariel: like introduction to accessibility.
Tariel: start scrolling down.
Tariel: Stop scrolling
Tariel: Now My use click. start, learning.
Tariel: right. click, star learning.
So I scroll it down.
Tariel: Stop scrolling
Tariel: show links.
Tariel: Choose 9.
Tariel: Oh, I like this. Everything look good. I'm able to click the arrows.
I'm close to more arrows. I'm
Tariel: say, click on about this ability to
Tariel: close it to simply close with the click. After I do that click, man, if that'll work, i'm use show links.
Tariel: If I show links, don't work again. I'll use my screen.
Tariel: and i'm a keep on looking through this this this this is really really good, too.
Tariel: Click about disability.
Tariel: click, screen, modification.
Tariel: click, screen matter for
excuse me.
Tariel: Show me.
Tariel: choose 11
Tariel: click, screen manifiers.
Tariel: click, alternative navigation.
Tariel: Choose 2.
Tariel: I like that, too. i'm able to say. Click on alternative navigation, and it's popped up 3 different locations that I choose to. So
Tariel: i'm getting my son your overall everything look good. I mean just the click back, arrow! That didn't work, but everything looked good. I was able to click on
Tariel: on the drop. Down means the arrows that.
Tariel: and latent some links.
Tariel: even the lake where it was able to click, open up a new but everything You look really good. I I I like your
If you found this Video.
Tariel: healthy.
Tariel: Oh, I hope you found this video helpful. Thank you.